la collection d'affichés de la
bibliothèque départementale est vraiment
exceptionnel puisque nous avons des
exemples est absolument remarquable
comme vous voyez ici
la collection a réellement débuté en
1981 il ya des traces d' affiches plus
ancienne mais dès 1980 la collecte des
affiches et systématique ce qui nous
permet aujourd'hui d'avoir près de sept
mille documents sept mille affiches qui
sont conservés à la bibliothèque
départementale de la réunion et qui
concerne toutes les thématiques de
l'impression réunionnaise la culture le
sport le tourisme les affiches aussi lié
aux associations notamment cultuelle
chinoise indienne etc
et c'est une collection qui s'enrichit
chaque jour un peu plus puisqu'il ya
environ sept cents affiches qui sont
déposés chaque année à la bibliothèque
départementale par les ai pris par les
imprimeurs et par les éditeurs et ça
nous permet d'avoir un patrimoine qui
tous les jours devient plus important
c'est une collection absolument
remarquable que nous possédons à la
bibliothèque départementale mais c'est
une collection qui bien évidemment est à
la disposition du public puisque notre
objectif c'est bien sûr de conserver ce
patrimoine imprimé mais aussi de le
mettre à la disposition de tous les
réunionnais donc vous pouvez vous public
vous rendre chez nous est demandé à
consulter ces affiches si elles
s'inscrivent dans une démarche
particulière et que vous en avez besoin
on